Oh internet internet wanted me to watch
this and so I did and alright Internet
let's talk about this tiger king so
Tiger King is a miniseries on Netflix
and I didn't know anything about this I
have no idea what I was getting into I
didn't know the story I know a lot of
people actually know a few people maybe
a couple of people
anyhow they knew the story they were
like oh yeah I totally knew the story
because it's on a podcast I listened to
it I was not so educated on the subject
so I went into this not even knowing
what it was all I knew was that there
were a lot of memes over the weekend
just this show got memed the [ __ ] out
it's a documentary miniseries following
the subculture if not shady world of
exotic animal owners and zoos that own
these Tigers and breeding and selling of
Tigers and it being this subculture this
little pocket of people everyone knows
everybody but when they hook you in with
this dude you can't help but just
chuckle you know it's wasn't a Magic
Mike or something like that hold on Joe
exotic that's it and you know that's
totally his name what look and you're
like I asked totally his name isn't it
yeah I imagine it would be
Joe exotic owns this zoo a lot of Tigers
is a really eccentric person he's like
if Joe Dirt and Yosemite Sam had a kid
with Siegfried and Roy yeah and yeah the
tagline of the show it just says it all
murder mayhem and madness it's quite a
story actually this dude was filming a
documentary with Joe exotic he's at the
very beginning of this series and he was
like you got to go to the beginning it's
a weird [ __ ] story
no one could phrase it better it is a
weird [ __ ] story it's a story that
it's an interesting insight into this
world this world I didn't know I would
be so interested in peeking into there's
also interesting among the people in
this world for a while in here it
concentrates on a feud between Joe
exotic and it's animal rights activist
and she's like well I'm helping the
animals and he's hurting animals and Joe
exotics like I love the Tigers they have
a good life here it's just so you have
two sides of this dispute in the end
they're both doing the same [ __ ] they're
profiting off of the exotic animals they
have for money that's what they're doing
and it doesn't stop there among all the
other characters in here it's like it's
the hypocrisy the finger-pointing the
self-righteousness among these adult
children and really the show is a
cautionary tale of letting those feuds
and escalation get out of control and do
not let that happen
I think the reason myself and a lot of
other people couldn't take our eyes off
of this thing is because we see it all
the time you see it on Twitter's I know
this person tweeted at me so I'll make a
youtube video about that tweet and that
person makes a youtube video about the
YouTube video I mean I see this [ __ ] on
YouTube all the time maybe the logistics
are different it's not people who own
zoos maybe they're not doing super shady
things like what's going on in the show
I suppose it's because that's this human
nature you know it is a subculture
anytime there's a subculture you have
pockets and cliques anytime you have
clicks you know have tribes anytime you
have tribes you have tribal warfare
that's just what people do we just we
drive it there so I see this as a
cautionary tale it's like don't let it
get here you know don't let it get out
of control at a point you look around
you're like no one in this show is a
role model no one is like everyone's
this shady character to varying degrees
but really no one's at that point where
you're like I respect you well none of
the owners anyway some some of the
people you know like some of the
bystanders maybe they were employees
maybe they were interns maybe they were
cult followers of some sort it's weird
but it's it's in its reality the other
ones really all right you're you're
human but these other idiots who are the
main ones who run these parks and they
just feel like the Lords of their
universe reality slip these folks awhile
ago
do these weird hypocritical narcissistic
egomania actually think to the center of
the [ __ ] universe right I'm on this
side of it you know so I got to remember
they're making entertainment so they're
gonna show us what they need to show us
to make good entertainment I don't know
if they're just showing the worst parts
of the people here but everyone in the
show just every park owner every tiger
owner everyone involved in the industry
firsthand just comes across as caddy no
pun intended it's just it's the word if
not that just general business scumbag
which brings me to my favorite meme I
found about this show ever and we'll put
it right there it's too good yeah you
win the internet for this month there
have been a lot of people on the
internet this month a lot of people's a
lot of
time so that's saying something when it
started ramping up in the show when it
was really getting heavy it's like
alright what's the angle this shows
gonna Paul and who's gonna be the hero
because of editing really the show never
says yeah this was the good guy and
that's the bad guy
he should it's bad decisions made by
egomaniacs accompanied by other
egomaniacs who helped along the bad
decisions and made other bad decisions
be careful here you go into business
with that's another lesson from here you
know there's actually a thing that
happens in here it can't be underplayed
it's legit tragedy that strikes you know
like oh my god I don't want to underplay
it and I don't want to not mention it
because it's easy for all the really
eccentric people that are a part of this
culture it's kind of eclipses that but
it's a really sad and tragic thing that
happened and it didn't need to happen I
just didn't want to not mention that you
know interestingly enough I want to keep
this one spoiler free but this might
this is like light spoiler because I
mean it doesn't really reach any
conclusion but there's this arc in here
it's quite a tangled web but on one of
them it's like oh this really rich guy
disappeared he just disappeared he's
pronounced dead he's gone but there's no
real it's like they investigate it and
they're like alright well we kind of hit
a brick wall so go back to the other
thing I would have wanted some
resolution with that but I mean you
can't make resolution up if there's no
resolution there's no resolution but it
definitely was one of those things rose
like what happened there that timings re
suspects this was one of those stories
where if this was a fictional story and
it was a series or a movie and I was
talking about it on YouTube I would be
like well they should have cut a couple
of storylines and focused it up the
story's kind of all over the place but
it's reality truth is stranger than
fiction it's just it's a story that
starts out in one area of people who own
Tigers and the culture they're in and it
just it goes to crazier avenues among
all these people who are they're
schemers schemers trying to control
their little worlds and in the end you
can tell the story's not done at all
there's more to tell absolutely all I
know is it is quite the bus fire that
you can't take your eyes off of whether
you see it for the subculture it starts
out on or you see it as the cautionary
tale of Internet beef by the end is
definitely worth a watch for the first
two episodes I was like
why did the Internet get me into folks
you suggested this weird [ __ ] actually a
couple of people I knew did too just it
felt like a reality TV but about halfway
through and [ __ ] starts to really get
shady and weird you it locks you in your
okay this isn't just some eccentric guy
who owns Tigers and whoop-dee-doo
interestingly enough I've seen better
documentaries out there but not
documentaries that are so me mobile if
someone like that well that [ __ ] goes
viral so here we are I've heard about
Tiger King so during social distancing
self-isolation self quarantine whatever
you want to call it there you got
yourself a miniseries if you want to
lock in and wonder why because I said
it's there right so Tiger king it's on
Netflix have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's another
documentary that you would suggest for
me I make no promises but always taking
orders whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here
does any more
[Music]